[Music]
[Music]
william we're back here we are done
how's it going that's fantastic how are
you you were uh smiling
as if you were smiling towards me but
you were actually smiling towards the
people at home i was going right down
what do they call that the barrel yeah
right down the barrel
like now i'm talking to you but looking
at the people at home but you're
actually talking to the people at home
and looking at me this is the opposite
of what i'm doing now have you ever have
you done that when you're working like
you when you're on a tv show or a movie
or something yeah and you're doing a
good scene and you're doing it with
somebody and then you go
yeah if you do it for too long it's very
noticeable but if you i've
kind of worked out that if you just kind
of flash your eyes across the camera no
one picks up on it even the cameraman
because at times i've been like i think
i look down the lens there you go oh no
i didn't see it at all obviously if you
do that you're in trouble but just
flashing across the lens is that all
right but i don't think people notice
all right good can you do this what
[Applause]
it's not a fault in the podcast can you
do that is the air going in or out it's
going in
i'm sorry all right
brilliant so we probably we probably
lost a few hundred subscribers but
that's all right that's all right we
gained two two people who were like wow
that's really nice high note yeah the
faithful have stayed with us what'd you
think of my jumper it's one of my
favorites fantastic it's got flies on it
yeah flies land on [ __ ] a lot it's true
yeah there's a lot of them on me what
does that say about well what's it
saying about you what made you feel as
though you should wear that well my
brother bought it for me it's one of my
favorite gifts that my brother's ever
bought for me because i remember when
when i opened it i thought
wow
there's not that many people
that know me well enough to know that i
would love a jumper covered in flies but
i genuinely would and there's also not a
lot of people that would love a jumper
covered in flies
but i would and dom there's a lot of
good reasons for hanging around with you
you know you're good fun thanks yeah
yeah and one thing
a good reason for hanging around with
you you're knowledgeable on animals yeah
i like animals so i know like a lot of
people out there i'm sure that flies
land on [ __ ] yeah
but why do they land on [ __ ] yeah it's a
good question do you know the answer
yeah this i think is musket domestica or
the common house fly which if i had the
chance to study insects again take a
couple of years out and study insects
again i would probably zone in on the
common house flight and you do see the
common house uh the common house flag on
feces i'm gonna call it from now on
uh-huh uh both human and uh other
animals as well as other flies and the
reason for that is because they lay
their eggs in the feces and then the
maggots will eat
the faces because there's a huge amount
of nutrients in
poo
so hold on then yeah so is it only
female flies that land on feces then
generally yeah although i would probably
put an argument forward to say that male
flies are also interested in the social
aspect of a huge amount of female flies
flying around
who so if you were to take a bag and
capture all the flies i'd say probably
85 to 90 of them will be female but some
of them will be male because they're
looking to mate they're hanging around
there because they know that a lot of a
lot of women women are hanging around
covering [ __ ] but
if we didn't have flies as an example of
a very important insect we would have a
massive amount of
human and animal waste sitting around
and degrading much slower than it would
do if you didn't have these animals
around so with you know someone's not
picked up after their dog within a few
days
less than a week that's probably
disappeared because of all the animals
using it for fuel if we didn't have
those animals you know not only would it
be disgusting but probably more chance
of disease and pestilence so it's
amazing the world is this amazing nature
machine
where everything's helping everything
though yeah it is incredible nature it's
good to have you hanging around to give
us those answers yeah and i am
fascinated by flies insects are my
all-time favorite animal
i would think in the insect world there
are different types that i'm more
fascinated by than others i really like
mantids i like beetles
but the reason why i would study flies
and specifically musket domestica the
common house fly is because they go
through a very fast life cycle they're
very easy to
work with and do experiments with
because there's a lot of them and also
they're everywhere we interact with them
all the time you know is our flies uh
found on every continent
no they're not found on our and
antarctica as far as i know there might
be some but i think like true flies i
don't think you'd find true flies in
antarctica it's too cold i would love to
have an entomologist
on the show
you almost don't need one because of you
yeah my understanding of of insects if
you got to like phd level is is very
much lacking degree level having a even
a biologist on or an entomologist to
talk to us about insects and just how
important they are would be fantastic
because unfortunately as we know
most people are a little disgusted by
insects or even
scared of insects and i would say 99
of insects on the planet are completely
harmless and 100 of them are useful so
it's time to re-educate ourselves if
you're an entomologist or if you know an
entomologist please get in touch with us
at
the friendship onion at
cassmedia.com let us know because we
like having interesting people on we
don't just have actors we do like having
actors of course don't get us wrong but
we don't just want actors
we we have astronauts and and physicists
and map makers yeah speaking of which
what well we should do a little bit of
housekeeping because we like to you know
make sure that we're up to date with
people studying correspondence and
someone sent us
a letter about daniel last week who was
making maps
so are we peeling the onion yeah we're
peeling the onion
peeling the onion
that's sentences from molly nesbit oh
and she said y'all so i feel like she's
from the south maybe sounds like it
certainly in america she said y'all
should ask daniel the map maker for a
commission of a map of billy's hand
with all the places you have guessed
exactly where you've guessed them that
would be some amazing merch that'd be
great and since someone told us to use
the thumb
as um
a florida it's really hard for me i've
got to start with this then turn my hand
upside down and then back that way right
let me get it right because i can never
think of it in my head yeah no it is
counting so um that'd be bright let's
get in touch with daniel could you do
that johnny yeah let's do that and uh
we'll we'll get me do a map of my hand
with all the wonderful places of the
united states
we should start doing the world and use
my head
yeah that would be brilliant um do you
want to read this letter here from jen
you may not have got my special action
put your specs on have you got a sheet
of paper yeah i've got one here right so
gents lovely jen jen says hello guys
i've been absolutely loving your podcast
since i found it last week people are
just finding it john oh is that right
yeah the friendship onion the friendship
onion
is one of only two podcasts i watch and
i listen to regularly the other being
normal not normal with oliver and james
phelps so i always think it would be
lovely if my four favorite podcasters
from my two favorite movie franchisees
and two favorite podcasts came together
as guests on each other's podcasts what
do you think and i dumb tell them
you tell them i'll tell them tell you
what the phelps guys uh were in touch
and they would like us to go on to their
uh podcast normal not normal and we're
going to do it i think next week yeah
next week i've met them and i really
like the guys did you meet him at a
convention no i met them because
well i don't know if that's a secret so
i better not see yeah as you know i've
seen it
i've seen it
i've seen it somewhere that uh they're
doing a travel show and i was i was
hoping to join them on in one of their
er
one of the places they were going but
because of
coving everything we're dealing with uh
the travel seemed too difficult and
impossible so i didn't but i spoke to
them and they're lovely people so we're
going to speak to them together next
week on normal not normal and hopefully
we'll have them on
our podcast at some point and we can
talk about being twins and if they can
if they can read each other's minds
which i think twins can't yeah and the
fact that sometimes people think that
you and i are the same person even
though we sound completely different and
i think look
different enough to not be confused with
each other like we're in the same movie
yeah but you know i have often had
people say in passing you were great in
mastering commander yeah now or are you
still making music yeah
no it was a shame what happened to you
and lost and why didn't you walk out the
door and people say
anyway spoiler alert hey we went to riot
should we talk about that very briefly
we went to the riot campus in santa
monica
in los angeles
after i think having made it relatively
public that you and i play
league of legends a few people reached
out to us and said we'd love to have you
come see us when we're not in a crazy
covid situation
and uh
we went with your lovely son and got uh
shown around the campus and it was very
impressive or as they would say in
spanish
it sounded it certainly was
bella bella grazie
what was your favorite part of it uh you
know
a lot of it wasn't open because of it
that was your favorite part yeah i like
everything being closed
no but the room where anyone who works
there could go down and play not only
league of legends but any video game on
you know really fast pcs and nice comfy
chairs and all that i thought if i
worked here that'd be fantastic
brilliant ielts they also had in front
of that
they had like a
would it would it be pretentious to say
homage no omash is a lovely one they had
like an homage to computer games or
video games around
over the decades so on the far left
you had one of the initial kind of
ataris that came out all the way up to
the far right there was a playstation 4.
and they said we anyone who wants to
play any console any game that can sit
here and do it brilliant and i asked mel
our host who took us around hello mel um
i asked mel what why do you guys do that
and she said well obviously we want
people to love and play league of
legends but we want them to stay in the
world of loving computer games or video
games for us because it'll help us in
our company so very cool
it made me think as well not right just
the word homage when i passed them
deaf death
when death comes upon me yeah would you
do a stage show a sort of homage to my
life is it a one-man show it's a one-man
issue
and it's it's song dance it's poetry
it's mixed media
i'm gonna write it before you die i'll
start writing it tonight okay and
oh the place the place will love it
it'll be great
yeah but the thing is
you're gonna die only about 18 months
before me so i'm going to be like 83 84.
if you haven't rehearsed though and
you're ready to go yeah
billy boyd
one [ __ ]
oh is that the final number yes billy
boyd what an [ __ ] curtain call thank
you good night everyone yeah that's
that's a great idea i'd love to thank
you doing homage to your death i'd love
that um but thanks to everyone at riot
yesterday there was a there was some
really cool kind of
big statues of champions from the game
annie they are the artwork that was
amazing i can't remember the name of the
artist that's terrible guy from um korea
uh and and they said
[Music]
they love them in korea and the thing
that he does it doesn't huge canvases
and he doesn't work it out he just
starts drawing yeah and there they were
beautiful brilliant i remember some of
the names of the people that showed it
around there was brielle it was brian it
was august it was josh there was joe mel
of course there was molly well done
um oh you haven't missed somebody i
definitely missed a few people so sorry
uh about that but thanks for all the end
for league of legends and some gifts and
we know secrets now yeah they've taught
us some secrets counseling
but apart from that
has been your time on on the rift we've
been having some fun haven't we yeah
they do a thing for people who don't
play league of legends yet but get on
we'll all get on one day everyone who
watches the friendship onion will all
get on and we'll play a big game of
league of legends rumble a big rumble
but they do a thing at the weekends
called it's a competition clash
clash but you have to be
ranked ranked
which means you have to play 10 games so
that they can see where you are in the
ranking system so i'm three games in
to being ranked and then once we're all
ranked we're going to play clash and do
competitions and i think that's the
first run
to becoming pro
yeah i think it is because the um
the finals this year we were told we're
in san francisco and we feel like maybe
we'll be playing in the final if we keep
going that's where you're going now well
they said that we'll definitely be there
we're invited when was it again it's in
like october november time
and so that gives us quite a few months
to become the greatest in the world at
that game yeah we also asked our friends
over at riot if they might have someone
at riot who could come onto the podcast
as a guest and maybe give the people at
home who don't play league of legends a
overview of what the game is about and
how you play it because the game can be
quite intimidating can't it well all
video games can be a thing well even
like
yeah
yeah
really i don't find that intimidating at
all really although actually sounds like
you don't want that
um yeah it's quite an overwhelming game
there's 150 champions and and more are
coming and there's a lot going on
but i think if we had someone from riot
coming and say
you know download the game don't worry
about this worry about that yeah because
that is more important than this
so we're going to get somebody from
league of legends to come on and talk
video games who else do we want to come
on this would be like a call to answer
we want an entomologist on entomologist
we want someone who who is a qualified
beer maker to come on somebody knows
about whiskey someone who knows about
wine someone who knows about cheese
someone who knows about the london
underground the london anyone out there
that's a london underground expert
billy's fascinated by it absolutely um
we've had a map maker on which is
fantastic
jeez
i'd like someone who's an expert on the
stock exchange
because to be fair
i don't really get it i don't get it and
the only time i have the money the only
time i ever tried that i lost all my
money
remember when the banks all dropped
well a friend of mine paul riley what's
up holzer he says
put your money in your banks i said hey
i've never bought shares he said get all
the money that you can spare put any
banks because they're going to go bust
and then they're going to have to do
something no no no they thought they're
going to go whoosh
and they went bust they were about i
think about two pounds 20 a share
and within a day
they were 20p
he's done you there hasn't it i lost all
my money my god i invested very early in
tesla and google
and i've done really really so that's a
that's a better story it's a great story
i'm cock-a-hoop i'm sitting pretty i go
to sleep on a large ball of money every
night billy you and i both love liquid
iv
love it dom now let me tell you i take
it before the gym i take it after the
gym and also because they've been so
generous with giving us their product
i've also given some of it to my trainer
and some of my friends at the gym and
they all absolutely love it so i mean
everyone that takes a liquid iv seems to
love it it's great i don't know if it's
because i'm getting used to it and i'm
used to like feeling good after i take
it but now you know like say i feel like
i'm going to do a workout and i'm sort
of starting the doze on the couch or
that and i think oh i might not do a
workout today
liquid iv
i'm right in the mood to work out again
yeah you said you'd prefer it more than
water which is an incredible thing to
say i love it designed to enhance rapid
absorption of water and other key
ingredients into your bloodstream liquid
iv is absolutely fantastic and one stick
of liquid iv in 16 ounces of water
hydrates faster and more efficiently
than water alone incredible and it's got
fantastic flavors watermelon strawberry
lemon anything you need pina colada is
one of my favorites
hey dom grab liquid iv and built
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
the code onion at checkout
that's 25 off anything you order when
you use the promo code onion
liquidive.com experience better
hydration today at liquid iv.com promo
code onion using the internet without
expressvpn
is like leaving your laptop on a table
in a coffee shop while you go to the
bathroom
fair enough
a lot of the time that's going to be
okay but one time you're going to come
back
and your laptop is going to be gone
and it's the same
if you're using the internet without
express vpn
if you're in a coffee shop or a hotel
or
an airport and using their wi-fi
if a hacker is on that system he can
very very easily get into your computer
and steal all your passwords financial
data
anything so whenever i use
the internet on someone else's wi-fi i
always use
expressvpn
they create
a encrypted tunnel
between your device and the internet
which makes it impossible for hackers to
steal your data so secure your online
data today by visiting
expressvpn.com
onion that's e x p r e s s v p n dot com
slash onion and you can get an extra
three months free
expressvpn.com
slash onion spills what else what else
is your well it's your wonderful wife's
40th birthday today as we record today
not when this goes out i would just like
to say my favorite thing about your wife
as as a tribute to allison on her 40th
birthday yeah my favorite thing about
your wife is that she always has smiling
eyes yeah she always looks like she's
about to do this
right yes she has quite a nice time i
think she enjoys she enjoys the world
which is probably a good thing crazy
we're all aging yeah every every the
only thing that makes it bearable is
everybody's getting older is that what
it is so your misery will eventually be
shared by us is that what you're saying
yeah when somebody goes ah you know as
some as people do online sometimes they
go oh wow you got old
i just think well everybody's getting
older yeah you too
like bono in the edge i mean
um i was larry mullen i was i was um
like throwing stuff out of my wardrobe
the other day things that i didn't need
putting them in putting them in plastic
bags and stuff and i put them all in a
big pile right and then i went
downstairs to grab bin bags to then put
all the stuff that had been thrown out
of my wardrobe that was now in a pile
into the bin bags and
ordinarily or in my in my younger days
that's just nothing you just you just
bend down and start playing closing
but i bend down to do it and i was like
oh my back oh what's that so i had to
like bend my knees and sit down in a
cross-legged position to do it those are
some some of the things they don't tell
you about when you're aging the the
normal everyday stuff
starts to become a little trickier and
you can twinge your back or hurt your
hip by doing stuff like that think about
start organizing an homage to you you
might be first to go what would be the
closing number yours is billy boy's an
[ __ ]
that's mine
and then he became king something like
that oh yeah yeah that's nice ruler of
the world cutting coal power
uh william blackout scream done
oh emails and real mails fastest tigers
slow as snails all right we've had some
emails
yeah so i'll tell you a few of these go
on top
this
comes from um
what a lovely name family
well that's that's a word that means the
people that are in no it's spelled
differently it's f-a-m-i-l-e
family
and she's from new zealand ah i've been
there
yeah bless you she says hello billy and
dom thank you so much for starting this
podcast i've been following you on it
ever since you hit 500 subscribers wow
not bad that was way back it was way
back she lives in new zealand she says
and i've visited weta workshop on almost
every lordaering's location i have one
strange question to ask both of you
if the first animal you see
suddenly says something in english to
you
what would be the first sentence of
words you'll say to it yeah complex
thanks so much guys and goodbye
so you've we've suddenly left the posca
podcast studio yeah and we see what is
it a pigeon yeah pigeon see a pigeon
and the pigeon says
so i'll be the pigeon the pigeon says to
you
you got any bread
and my answer my question is it a
question or what would i say yeah my
sentence back yeah would be
how long have you been able to
communicate with humans and can all of
you do it
and the pigeon would say
no no
you say
yeah
but
can i we're intellectually above you
as are all other animals
yeah so we haven't brought ourselves to
speak to you because you're scum and
your ivory towers mm-hmm
you're all scared but i could really go
some bread yeah how about that bread
have you guessed we can't work out how
you make that
i will tell you i know a little bit of
trivia about a pigeon
they eat dandruff
from off who well i was with my mate
right um
dandruff dave now i can oh martin
waterhouse we went into stockport
and he was sat on a bench and he went
watch this there's a whole bunch of
pigeons around our feet and he put his
head down
scraped his scalp and a whole bunch of
my favorite word
it
it's great to drop latin every so often
yeah uh a whole bunch um carpe diem a
whole bunch of um detroiters fell off
his head and the pigeons all scrapped
around eating it and he looked me clean
in both eyes and he said pigeons eat
dandruff
i thought okay that's great and then did
he work that out
maybe his dad told him not sure
i love that well i'll do the same thing
am i still a pigeon or can i be
something else uh you can be a fly if
you want okay so you come out the
podcast studio and sat on the bonnet of
your car yeah musket domestica the
common house fly yeah and he goes hey
what
are you moving this car anytime soon
because i'm enjoying the warmth from the
engine and you say i'm actually just
going to head off now because i have to
get back it's my wife's birthday and
we're going out for tea congrats that's
all right well by the way why are you
always hanging around [ __ ] in fact don't
bother telling me my friend tom just
told me
so on your way brilliant all right i'll
buzz off see ya see you later
brilliant i read a comic book when i was
young
and it was about flies
it doesn't doesn't tell you it's flies
it's you've seen it through someone's
eyes
flies eyes but we don't know it's a fly
right and it's aliens and they all come
down and they're in uh
alien ships and it never gives you the
point of view of us looking at them so
we're only seeing the world from
aliens
and they're coming in the earth and
they're like we're going to take over
this planet
and they'll land it and then they come
out and then for the first time you see
a human
you see it it comes in the door and he's
like let's kill this human
you know and the human turns around and
just whacks it and that's when you find
out that it's flies wow so we've always
had these aliens on earth but they've
always been flies and we don't know the
railings
as a young boy
sitting in crown hill glasgow reading
that i was i was quite taken they've
been around a lot longer than us flies
like hundreds of millions of years and
modern day humans have been around for
100 000 years 125 000 years tops you
know yeah they took oh another person
who would love to have on a mushroom
expert because i was going to say
mushrooms are neither plant nor animal
they're in their own group and that
particular group can survive in the
vacuum of space so one of the things put
forward is that mushrooms are actually
aliens that they don't come from space
that are from earth that they've been
flying through space managed to
colonize here but ultimately they're
they're in the
deep
expanses of space it'd be great to have
a mushroom expert on i've just thought
of somebody who'd be brilliant i don't
know if they'll come on because they're
very busy is it obama no but you were
talking about people and uh how how long
they've been on the earth and all that i
know a couple of archaeologists
from the stone age institute
and i'm going to ask them if they'll
come on how do you know them
it's a long story though
they gave me a skull
not a real one no you're human yeah
why would they give you a fake human
skull
so that you can
it's a very famous skull
is it yeah but it's a fake one i don't
understand they've given you a fake
famous human skull yeah so they dug a
guy why are you being suspicious a guy
in africa dug up their skull and it
proves something ah
i can't remember what it proves this is
what they would tell us yeah
possibly possibly possible
that we thought humans
were around yes or when their brains
were a certain size or whatever
anyway i'll get them on they'll discuss
all this yeah yeah we'll dig into it
well that's where the other day
hi guys really enjoy the show thanks for
doing this and it's literally just been
announced on twitter and youtube and all
those places that uh dom you're playing
uh or voicing playing
uh archibald desnay in the uh the legend
of vox machina the critical row
critical role
i'm so excited critical role and
animated series according to amazon
prime at the end of the month we're
really hoping that you could just tell
us a little bit about that experience
how you sort of came on board
and whether we'll be seeing you
at the campaign three table on critical
role
at any time soon
that sounded like either ed sheeran or
tom holland or maybe both
yeah maybe it's tom sheeran yeah holland
um
thanks for your question
it's very exciting to be involved even
in a minor way with critical role
i think it happened based on a couple of
crossover events that occurred
one being that i started doing a
dungeons and dragons online campaign
during
covet shutdown or lockdown and i think a
few people found out about that and
maybe the critical role people found out
about that
maybe excuse me and then i was lucky
enough to play one of the characters in
the recent call of duty game
and the
lovely lady laura bailey who played the
russian sniper is also one of the major
cast members of critical role
so
between her and her husband who's also
in critical role i think he said well
don plays dungeons and dragons yeah he
seems to be a nice enough guy on set
yeah
let's ask him to come in and i play
archibald disney
who is a kind of gruff
scottish talking dwarf he speaks like
that archibald and he's great and he's
like does a lot of like
war cries let's [ __ ] go and in uh
homage to you at one point i said
you [ __ ] dobber because i thought
that's very scottish and everything very
scottish um
tons of fun
i've been lucky enough to see a little
bit of the um the way that the show
looks
and it looks really exciting and um
yeah can't wait to see it those guys are
amazing brilliant the stuff they're
doing
we should have them on because they've
got an amazing story we should they they
did the fastest kickstarter campaign in
the history of kickstarter so they had
asked people
uh
for a certain amount of money i can't
remember what but they'll tell us if
they come on and they got something like
eight times the amount of money that
they asked for i think the the the
headline said they kicked kickstarter
right in the [ __ ] is that right i
think it said that amazing so then they
turned it into this amazon prime show
and um i think it comes on at the end of
the month
and you will be wonderful don well
there'll be a lot of people showing up
in that show and it will be further more
and more exciting so check it out the
legend of vox machina the legend of vox
machina thanks tom holland and ed
sheeran for your question
here comes another one
hi guys my name is lydia and i'm a
swedish girl living in devon
and i listen to your podcast i can work
every day absolutely love it so keep up
to good work
i want to start with billy i actually
met you um in london at the last hobbit
movie premiere
well you actually walked right past me
at first but then you came back just to
tell me that you had to run to lou first
but you're probably one of the nicest
person i've ever met and i brag about
that to people to this day that i've met
you
so my question to you guys is so you
obviously both travel loads for work and
projects and you've been away from
family and partners for long periods of
time
i just want to want to know what your
best tips are to keep a long distance
unless you're going because i'm actually
in one and i would love to hear your
advice
keep up the good work love the podcast
bye
relationship investor
she sounds like um it could be an abel
and sebastian uh song linear i'm a
swedish girl living in london devin i
thought devon yeah
certainly in england though i've moved
now you can probably speak more on
successful
relationships that are long long
distance because my ones have
generally failed which i would i would
uh
term as a relationship
relationship
but you're in a successful situation i
think
i think um
i think a sort of mutual respect isn't
it to what the other people uh people
i'm like god monogamous this is news to
me
the other person is doing so it's it's
sort of really nice to share life with
someone
but you have to kind of respect that you
can't be totally together you know yeah
you'll be off doing this or that but and
they'll go off and do this and that but
you you're still together you know so i
think
um you know as as you have to go to
devon
there has to be a sort of
um understanding that that's something
that you're doing for whatever reason
and sort of you you give each other that
kind of loose rope to do your thing but
knowing that you're still together i
think that's a big thing i think some
people feel like oh if i'm not
geographically close to you then we
can't be together because you've you've
went off but you know life is like that
it's all sort of moving and swaying and
you know it's nice when you meet someone
that you want to share that with but you
don't have to be tied
to a short rope
yeah yeah because that's always going to
fail isn't it if you're on a short rope
together yeah and also like that phrase
uh goes
is it um
oh god abscess makes the fart go honda
no it's not that abstinence
makes the love last longer is that right
something like that um
yeah
that's a beautiful thing it can be
challenging to be away from people that
you love and and not just your
significant other whoever they are
sometimes it's sad to be away from kids
and family members and friends and stuff
but just having that continuing dialogue
is important right like
you can't disappear out of someone's
life just because you're not
geographically there phones are an
amazing thing i know we give them a hard
time and i certainly give my phone a
hard time but the ability to stay in
touch especially with face time and all
that now
yeah so i think i'll be okay get him to
write your song er i'm a swedish girl
living in devon lovely linear but one
day i'll see you again thank you thank
you lania
for your lovely question
billy what a lovely answer thank you
dom a great way to start your day and a
healthy way to start your day important
magic spoon cereal lovely aren't they
fantastic i love them i love them and i
like the taste of them and
my son was telling me because he's he's
been lifting weights recently he says a
lot of weight lifters are eating magic
spoon now because of all the protein in
it yeah we grow up eating a lot of
cereal but unfortunately a lot of cereal
when we were kids is full of sugar and
things that are bad food that is not the
case with magic spoon we're all trying
to eat better
but healthy breakfast doesn't have to be
boring magic spoon has some amazing
flavors that you'll love but without all
the bad stuff and it's amazing as a
midnight snack right before bed so
listen to this zero grams of sugar 13 to
14 grams of protein which is great after
a workout and only four net grams of
carbs in each serving is keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free and low
carb and you can build your own box dom
available flavors to build your own
custom bundle cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter blueberries cinnamon
cookies and cream and maple waffle super
yummy so go to
magicspoon.com to grab a custom bundle
of cereal and start your new year off
right and be sure to use our promo code
onion at checkout to save five dollars
off your order and magic spin is so
confident in their product it's back
with a 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no questions asked
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal at magicspoon.com
onion and use the code onion to save
five dollars off thank you magic spoon
for sponsoring this episode
from websites to online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business they offer so much
like video blogs traffic overview email
campaigns social sharing and so much
more i love squarespace because it's
really easy to use and like you said
bills offer so many tools to help you
track your business needs i myself have
tried squarespace and have a lot of fun
building my pages with analytics you can
gain powerful insights into who's
visiting your site and how they're
interacting with your content with our
in-depth website
analytic tools include page views
traffic sources time on site most read
content audience geography and more
squarespace takes the guesswork out of
search engine optimization for your
website which means you'll get found in
search by more people more often buying
a domain from squarespace is simple
because there are no hidden fees or
price hikes each domain comes with an ad
free parking page head to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
onion to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain billion dom eat the world
hello here we are you join us here in
the all expenses spared uh stage for
billion dom eat the world and we will in
fact eat the world very slowly one
mouthful at a time now william yes this
week it looks like we're eating ramen
which is a noodle snack from i don't
know what what asian
country i would say korea i would say
japan
but let's agree to disagree okay
but we're not just eating ramen no we're
eating ramen with here we are momo fuku
chili crunch
as you can see here and we'll do a much
better
uh focused section of that give us over
here john great on eggs noodles and all
your favorite dishes thanks
sent to us by a listener
we've forgotten the name of the listener
unfortunately but johnny cruz will find
us find it for us maybe not right now
at some point in the future some point
in the future says johnny clues yeah
what
we are going to do yeah is it's supposed
to be relatively hot but we're like
oh thank you we're going to put a little
bit of it i would say for me i would say
probably a teaspoon right what's this a
fork spoon yeah i need it we need a
spoon don't we really that's right
i'm gonna do two of those tea fork a tea
forks
in your rag doubler give it a little
stir i'll do that tom
yeah we both like spicy food but john
almost johnny clothes almost choked on
it earlier on yeah his heart blew off
his hat did blow off well that looks
good tell you what it looks good now i'm
going to read a little bit about
momofuku it says here ever since the
early days of momofuku they've been
working on a chili oil that has heat
texture umami that crazy flavor that we
all know and a proper balance of flavor
the results the result is momofuku chili
crunch the story of how they got there
is a journey that takes us from america
to china to mexico with a quick stop in
denmark now should we try it first why
are you stopping denmark no i don't know
right okay here we go dom
more more foucault jelly crunch
all right here we go right go undo
it's hot
you've got a little bit on your face but
not too bad good
oh yeah
it is hot i like the crunch i like the
crack i like the heat
the sides of your tongue oh i'm gonna
have another bite go on this is
fantastic do you like it
i'm gonna could you
put some
maybe i'll just do it myself you know
and so i make sure that i'm definitely
that's what i'm tasting oh that is a lot
look at that done treat yourself
is that a good buy should i do that
what
yeah
um
all the crunch is good the crunch
and just to be a hundred percent and
i've just licked this sorry about that
no no
i put the other end you and i are
basically family or whatever you want
not me no just of stuff
i'm gonna eat that so i know i'm
definitely getting the flavor okay
i'm a big fan of umamu now umamu things
are things like seaweed
and what else is umami that's a
different food
it's like a multi uh um um fermented
flavor what did they say that's the sex
flavor or the food
so the salt
and sneezy yeah
and umamu but seaweed is an example of
an umami taste what else is i think
marmite maybe is umami yeah i would
think so don't i really like that i
would describe that as [ __ ] fantastic
isn't it good that's great
do you know what's in it no guam what
can i guess
chili flakes
right what kind of oil
i'd say
corn seed oil very close rapeseed oil
what rapeseed oil rapeseed no no but
even coarser
than than is it's beginning with an r
now it begins with the g and you've got
all the rest of it
grape seed oil grapeseed oil chilies yes
is there any nuts in there
i got a nutty thing but no no no
seaweed you got seaweed
seaweed
um
various spices mm-hmm there's a sugar in
it but it's not a normal tube molasses
healthy sugar what would the healthy
sugar no not count sugar brown sugar it
might fall off a tree and kill you
coconut coconut sugar
garlic sesame seeds yeah so i should
have said chili's mushroom powder salt
shallots spices yeast extract oh yeast
extract
that's a new mommy flavor and i think
mushrooms are a new mommy flavor
seaweed yeah
mushrooms umamu yeast extract well it's
very umami it's very tasty let's read a
little bit more about
very very good as a child
mo ku [ __ ] that's the um
name of the company moku fuku's creator
dave
his favorite sources were the vinegary
oily chinese chili sauces from
restaurants like wu garden and
gourmet in near his hometown in virginia
later after moving to new york he began
eating a lot of i'm gonna hopefully get
this right lao gan ma very good chili
crisp the chinese
uh condiments sorry beloved by
knowledgeable cooks around the world
when momofuku our product right here
first began serving roast
ducks at sambar chili crisp was one of
the og condiments now i can imagine that
to be very good on something like egg
fried rice done
that's fantastic it's really good
because it doesn't overpower but it's
very spicy and i love that crunch we've
almost eaten half the jar
dom i'm going to get down to why we we
said copenhagen you ready
so a few years ago while cooking at an
event in copenhagen dave the guy who
started it yeah improvised another
crunchy chili oil using a variety of
smoky sweet and dried chilies chef rocio
sanchez who provided the chili said it
reminded her a bit of salsa matcha never
had that a thick oily salsa she loved to
spin on everything from tacos to rice
bowls speaking of tacos they first tried
salsa seca a lesser known but no less
delicious dry salsa at eastside tacos in
l.a and in fact led us to create a dish
of butterball potatoes with crispy dried
garlic shallots and sesame seeds at
mahodomo brilliant i'm gonna give you so
basically he was at an event in
copenhagen and because of the chili's
that he used uh there was a chef there
who who did a spanish food mexican food
and um
said it reminded her of a salsa does it
remind you of a salsa i mean a little
bit i would say it's like a
it's a chilli oil but specifically kept
the crunch in
because a lot of times when you're
making a chili oil the heat of the oil
is going to make everything soft but
they've managed to use things that keep
that wonderful
crunchiness and sometimes you need that
with things like noodles or rice that
are all kind of squishy so the
difference is this sort of um unami base
is that right yeah i think so so that's
what makes it different read this part
here and get some of that that's quite
interesting i'd love to hang on
with momo fuku chili crunch they the
company are proud to join this
incredible tradition of crunchy spices
from around the world
excuse me they spent years tinkering and
experimenting in their kitchens in order
to create a chili oil that reflects all
of the various inspirations and speaks
to specific tastes
they used the same umamu base as
momofuku seasoned salts so i guess they
did that yeah
plus a lot of flavors and textures that
they love like crispy shallots
sesame seeds dried garlic coconut sugar
for a hint of sweetness and it also says
here we love msg but this product only
contains ingredients that are naturally
high in glutamic acid now i wanted to
talk to you about msg yeah because
msg
for a long uh while there was kind of a
villain in the food world wasn't it
it gives you migraines yes it does this
it does that you should always ask for
no msg in uh in chinese restaurants or
asian restaurants supposedly that was
all nonsense msg doesn't do any of those
things
yeah really yeah it does you know it's
okay it's fine msg it's not attributed
with any health issues as far as i know
so all those
not a doctor all those restaurants i had
to change their the recipes because
people said i don't want that yeah it's
giving me migraines it's all that kind
of stuff this
is i'll tell you what
it's going to get high scores this let's
go for it taste
taste and or flavor i'm going i'm going
to drink the soup
to get a real taste of it all right i'll
do that and hold on
i mean
no question it has improved this ramen i
would say at least
four times
better so we're already getting onto
usefulness but i'll get back to you
taste taste i'll let you uh recover i'm
i'm giving it a
i'm going to give it a 9.7 that is a
fantastic tasting chili crunchy i'm
going to very quickly follow you up
there with a 9.5 brilliant
repeating
i think it's more than noodles than that
now how does it look the aesthetics the
jar and the product itself the jar's
quite
small and dainty and sweet
i like it i like that i like the text
the font that they've used it's quite
playful isn't it
oh zoom in but it won't be in focus so
there's no point really it looks
roasting hot it's not quite as hot as it
looks though yeah
but
you're very confident shaking that
aren't you yeah i was nervous but i've
got a very very solid grip you do yeah
um
it does look nice i like that why's it
go what's that an orange a lemon yeah it
looks like an ice but you don't have
that in there didn't it no
grape seed is it the grape seed oil no
it's not grape oh see it's leaking
you're gonna have to demo a couple of
things there's because the liquid looks
um i'd like to as soon as we get sent up
by that lovely person that sends it yes
thanks lovely person we'll include your
name in the show notes absolutely um
don't worry he sometimes does this maybe
a little bit of water john
because billy's dying don't worry
there's help coming what happened there
you have a mini stroke up the back of my
nose my god but that's a good thing
right
there's water coming in
john oh john just in time john you've
absolutely saved us thank you john you
were just about to give it scores for
looks looks i'm going to give it an 8.2
i love it it looks like fire it looks
like everything that i like in food
spice
crunchiness texture umami
i'm gonna give it herb
9.7 again it's high high scores now
usefulness and here's where it really
comes into your soul
because if that is sitting in my
wherever you've got to keep it ladder
pantry yeah not fridge no no i wouldn't
say sorry because of the oil
preserving it so
that would sit next to my jardin era
which we've done before and that thing
we get through two jars of that a week
that's fantastic
so this thing would sit next to it and
it'd be just as if not more useful i
think yeah
recipes
eggs
on a piece of cheese and noodle i mean
that made like a cheap thing of noodles
tastes absolutely fantastic dumb on
right on your pizza maybe i've never
for usefulness
i'm giving it a 10 my first ever 10.
ladies and gentlemen one moment one
momentous moment here well people will
remember that yeah they will i'm gonna
give it
because i i have to say i probably still
think jardiner is a little bit more
useful than that and i can't remember
what usefulness i gave to chad in there
i'm giving it a nine i love it
i love normally that you think of
usefulness is can you take it on the
train can i put it in my pocket
and hours later offer it to hungry
people
which i don't think you could i'm a
little nervous good girl nine's great
high scores
for
momofuku chili crunch i wonder what momo
fuku means and i would guess that's
japanese would think
it's it's absolutely wonderful get
yourself some of this yeah
thank you very much the listener who
sent is it it's amazing we'll include
your name in the show notes if you've
got anything that maybe you grew up with
or maybe you went traveling and you
found something that you just thought
was
incredible that we can get hold of and
taste
on our show maybe it's bizarre maybe
it's super tasty we don't mind get in
touch with us
at the what is it the friendship onion
at castmedia.com or on
speakpipe.com forward slash the
friendship onion it's true
thanks guys
it's time for
i will take the ring
hey hello audrey hello ellie
hello
how are you guys doing
doing good yeah are you guys
no we're uh 13 months apart so close
enough 15 months
very close to being twins who would you
say before we even begin
to have a quiz with you guys who would
you say is the lord the rings expert out
the two of you
uh i feel like i'm the movie one and
she's the book
oh well there could be trouble here
now how do we pick teams you had a way
of doing this at one point yeah i closed
my eyes
you i said a number them numbers one
say for instance sally one audrey two
and then now my nasty
one is with me okay that kind of thing
okay close your eyes then hey
so audrey your number
okay all right billy open your eyes okay
i
will
my
audrey oh no no you're saying number
yeah he's a number that's right
one
you're with ally and i'm with audrey
come on ally here we go we're going to
win this
we got time for a quiz hey do you have
like a jingle for ready oh we have to do
acapella did you forget we don't have a
guitar do you know the answers to the
questions that we'll ask do you know the
answers
do you know the answers to the questions
that we'll ask do you know the answers
will you
take
wonderful stuff well i'm going to cross
my legs so i feel like a real question
master here so will you take the ring
tomorrow oh yes no so you have to you
have to um
answer back do you do you guys know what
you have to say yeah
yeah you say it together yeah yeah will
you take the ring to mordor
but do you know the way
but do you know the way
let's find out come on john all right
well it's like so i'm asking audrey's on
my team so i'm asking ally the questions
you're asking
okay and ally can ask me for one clue
and audrey can ask you for one clue
there's four questions each with a tie
breaker if you're if you're uh
drawn at that time all right ally are
you ready quite difficult
here we go
alec question one
where was mount doom located within
mordor
was it
the plateau of
gorgaroth
was it the plateau of osgiliath
was it the plateau of udon
or was it the plateau of eisenmouth i
can give you those four again if you
want or you can just go ahead and answer
okay i'm going to think about it yes
i did not want any geography questions
well that's a shame because this one is
almost certainly geography if i could
give you a piece of advice
use your mind use your brain
to create words that form an answer and
then have them fall out of your mouth
i'm going to ask you to read it one more
time here we go uh options a b c or d so
it is where was mount doom located
within mordor the plateau of gorgaroth a
the plateau of osgiliath be the plateau
of udon c or the plateau of eisenmouth g
okay i'm
thinking c
is that your final answer
yes
it's not my right answer
unfortunately i'm so sorry
uh the the answer is the plateau of
gorgaroth quite a hard question to start
very difficult to start you shouldn't be
ashamed of yourself
audrey another quite difficult one i
think yes
cinderin
is the language of which race
a dwarfs b
elves
c
hobbits or d
ends
the language of
cinderin
uh i'm gonna say ants
it is i'm afraid the wrong answer is
was the language
so it's zero zero so we're still drawing
so that's quite good john carry on okay
here we go now am i am i i'm asking ally
questions right is that right it is
right yeah ali's on my team oh yes so
ali question number three where were the
glittering caves located another
geography question unfortunately ally
i can't believe this i'm so sorry about
this where were the glittering caves
caves located
was it the misty mountains the white
mountains
mount doom
or the blue mountains
saddest mountains of course
i'll give you that question one more
time uh ali what you're thinking these
are very difficult yes talking question
where are the glittering caves located
a the misty mountains b the white
mountains c mount doom or d the blue
mountains close to virginia
just trying to imagine it trying to
imagine trying to imagine i don't know
it's total gas i'm gonna go with the
white mountains
it's the correct answer
ally fantastic word
one point now can we keep it one each
with the answer to this one uh audrey
here we are
which of these three
are not considered
what oh hold on
which of these three
are not considered
johnny
i don't like your wording on this
i'm going to give you
four time periods of arthur
one of them is not considered one of the
great three time periods of arda
so the four time periods are
the years of the lamp
years of the sun
years of the moon
or years of the trees
which of the three are not considered a
great time period in ardha
is that correct yeah
tough question tough question year of
the lamp
years of the sun
years of the moon
or years of the trees
which of the three are not considered
the three great time periods in ardha
i'm gonna go with a a years of the lamp
i would have went for that but it's the
wrong answer i'm afraid it's years of
the moon
who would have known that i don't know
stephen colbert maybe maybe it's one
nail to ally one nil ally's in the lead
i feel like the questions get a little
easier to get easier
which hobbit
is mary brandy buck me
first cousins with
is it a sam
b frodo c pippin or d rosie cotton
which hobbit is merry brandy book first
cousins with sam frodo pippin or rosie
it's pippin right
is that your final answer
it is
i'm afraid it's wrong nice frodo here
i was thinking
that in the movie yes well
well here we are we're all here to learn
okay audrey
who became the 32nd thing of the shire
that is the military leader in the shire
the 32nd thing was it a pippen
b frodo c sam or d bilbo who became the
32nd thing of the shire
heaven
it's the correct answer and it's one
each wow so very exciting now sisters
from minneapolis or mississippi or
wherever it is incredible work
okay
question seven ali
one you get this if you've seen the
movie
where in middle earth were the urak hai
bread
a model
b eisengard c
or d
ethylene
where would the urukai bred where were
they born where were they created
mordor eisenguard australia
is that your wow is that your final
answer
yeah it's the correct answer she was
absolutely sure of that audrey you need
this to stay in the game you need this
one audrey
i know
who
who owned
one of the best mushroom fields in the
shire
was it a farmer hopkins b
farmer moon
c farmer maggot or d farmer cotton
who owned one of the best mushroom
fields in the shire
you can ask for a clue of course
if needed
yeah
uh
i think i'm gonna ask brooklyn okay so
in the fellowship of the ring
when you meet
mary and pippen for the first time no
what
for the second time
the second time you meet mary and pippen
they have stolen something from a
farmer's field
it's that farmer
who has one of the best mushroom fields
in the messiah
farmer maggot
he's hickenly sansa and it's two each
and we go to a tie break and we can't
believe it's too exciting ah this is
very exciting now how are we going to do
the [ __ ] the tiebreaker because the two
of them have to answer this question at
the same time well that what we're going
to do is
i think you just shout it out he just
shouted out the first person it showed i
don't think we give him any options no
there's no options there's no options
first person that shouts out the correct
answer gets a
friendship onion t-shirt for free wow
what could be nicer okay go on you need
out bills
so just shout it out if you know it
how many oscars
how many oscars did the fellowship of
the ring win
i believe it was three
wrong
keep going
one goal each no then until somebody
gets it
i'm gonna say
i'm just gonna say four
is the correct answer
audrey
you have one the question this is
unbelievable
but no one can believe it incredible
gold mad wow
hey congrats ladies what a wonderful
quiz now
those are quite difficult hard questions
we we usually uh traditionally
see if
you guys want to ask us a question since
we've been asking you questions this
entire time so if you guys have a
question you can totally ask us if you
don't have a question that's okay too
well done that was a fun quiz well done
guys
yeah yeah thank y'all yeah um i do have
a question okay um
this is for billy yes
um
why
how did you come up with
we bobby johnson for your dog no that's
a good question my dog is called we
bobby johnson as you know i love him and
what happened was
we moved into a new house
and i was setting up the wi-fi
and my son would have been about seven
or eight years old
and i'm setting up the wi-fi you know on
my phone
and he's passing by and i said what will
i call the wi-fi
and he said bobby johnson
like just out of the blue so i said okay
and i called it bobby johnston
so the wi-fi was called bobby johnson
for about three years and then we got a
dog
and
we thought what we're going to call this
little dog and my son says bobby johnson
so we called the dog after the wi-fi
which was named after just my son saying
the first name it came into his head but
dom tells me
that bobby johnson is a famous scottish
football player soccer player
and we didn't know this yeah so we don't
know if my son had sort of heard that
somewhere but when i asked my son he
said no i just made it up i don't know
yeah so that's how bobby johnson is
called bobby johnson
good question what a great question
it was lovely spending time with you
guys thanks for playing the quiz with us
a minute does ali have a question oh
wait do you have a question ellie thank
y'all
um yeah i'll ask a question um
i just wondered like since y'all lived
multiple places in the world like how
y'all like living in america do you all
enjoy is it so different from anything
else or
how y'all like it yeah i love it i love
anywhere that i live i try and
make the best of it
los angeles is a little too hot for me
in the summer so by the time it gets to
kind of
may through till september it's a little
bit too hot for me but
the restaurants are amazing and the
things that you can do here are really
incredible yeah i really like it i think
america is a lovely place and it's so
big and so different that you can travel
around and you know when i first came i
couldn't believe how few people had
passports
but then i'd never lived in a big
country like america before where you
can spend a lot of time just looking
around america
and like you guys are from mississippi
let's see if dom knows where mississippi
is
there's my hands on
florida
california new york
where is mississippi no i don't know i'm
not very good with mississippi i would
say
if you go to the end of your index
finger and then go down no the other way
then go down a little bit towards your
thumb but not quite like going a little
bit stop i would say there
how's that
is that close to mississippi yeah it's
pretty close very very close
yeah well done okay okay
brilliant and what
let's ask you guys what's your favorite
thing about mississippi if you've if
you've been to other states in the
united states what's the best thing
about little ole miss i think best thing
is probably just small town life like
you know everybody around you and it's
just a special way to live so
nice yep yeah that's um
i sent y'alls um one of your producers
the recipe
from my family's restaurant
um so hopefully in the next few weeks
y'all will have eat the world and either
have white wine cake or poppy seed
chicken casserole white wine cake i'm
into that all that's ready it's bizarre
and brilliant what's your family's
restaurant and where is it found in
mississippi
um my it's my family-owned restaurant so
it's called penny's pantry
um there's just one store and it's in
san antonio mississippi just a small
place oh cool well hopefully we can go
there one day that'll be wicked that'd
be great mississippi is a very big one
spell it
well done
hey guys it was lovely to speak to you
have a fantastic rest of your day
well
i've had some fun dom another week is
over well we've got to leave it we've
got to leave the studio and get back to
normal life
yeah that was fantastic we've had a lot
of fun today in the world and talking
about different stuff and of course
doing a quiz with lovely people i like
the quizzes it's good
difficult questions this time john well
done if you want to get in touch with us
obviously you guys know how but you can
always leave messages for us on our
youtube channel and if you subscribe and
give us a five star review and raters it
gives us the chance to make more and
more of these episodes which we love
making for you rate review and subscribe
you can get our merch at the podcast no
at the podcast at the friendship
onionpodcast.com
and it's guaranteed that it'll make you
24
cooler
yeah well and we'll see you guys
next week on the friendship onion
toodles
[Music]
my pearl
[Music]